hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in the second part of the ethics of
ambiguity where simone de bevoir is
examining a number of different types
or modes of inauthenticity on the part
of human beings in relation to their
freedom
the last type that she discusses
is the passionate person and she frames
this at first by saying that this this
is the antithesis
of the adventurer but also has some
things in common but is different from
the serious person so we should look at
that very briefly because the
ways in which she's going to discuss
this might seem a bit paradoxical
so she tells us that in the passionate
person subjectivity fails to
fulfill itself and that is different
than the adventurer because in the
adventurer
she says it is the content which does
not succeed
in being genuinely fulfilled what is the
content the thing that the adventurer is
striving
after their subjectivity is being
fulfilled because they want to be able
to move from
thing to thing and have all sorts of
adventures
by you know ways of living out their
freedom
in the the passionate person there's
something
involved in the subjectivity itself that
is not being
adequately fulfilled although she says
that they both
do in fact have a sketch of the
synthesis
of freedom and its content right now
in the serious person they set up an
object as absolute and that is being
done with the passionate person
but there's a difference here in the
serious person
the object is being granted this
absolute this unconditioned status it
it is more important than everything
else for the passionate person
it's precisely because of the passionate
person's
subjective relationship to this thing
that gives the thing that transcendent
value
so a prime example of this is in
love now she's going to talk about love
in a little bit a different way
towards the end of this section but the
lover
the one who says oh only in my
eyes does the beloved attain the
wonderful status that he or she
has you know i'm the one who reveals
them as the beautiful person the
the wonderful you know thinker all this
potential that they
have so i'm really the one who is the
key
i'm the one who's the revealer of this
nobody else
can see in you what i see in you
and so there's there's a certain
duplicity involved right the object is
being
set up as this absolute but it's an
absolute for
me and i'm the one who makes it absolute
so in a certain sense
i'm the absolute and i'm using the other
you know as sort of like almost a
ballast to push off
against and so she she goes on and she
says
there are transitions between the series
and passion
a goal which was first willed in the
name of the series can become the object
of a passion inversely
a passionate attachment can wither into
a serious relationship but real passion
asserts the subjectivity of its
involvement
in amorous passion particularly
one does not want the beloved being to
be admired objectively you don't want
other people saying
oh yeah this person is really hot this
person is really smart
this person is really funny you want
them to be
funny for you that you're the one who
can reveal what's so
great about them same thing with other
things this
this dish is so you know sublime
because i'm the one who eats it i'm the
hipster
who has discovered this group i mean we
can see the hipster is the passionate
person
in a certain respect as well so
um a little bit further she says this is
the genuine thing
offered by all passion um revealing the
worth revealing the value of the thing
the moment of subjectivity therein
vividly asserts itself
in a movement towards the object it's
only when the passion has been degraded
that it ceases to choose itself as long
as it remains alive
it does so because subjectivity is
animating it and here she talks about a
couple different
modes of affectivity of passion
pride i'm so great that i can realize
how wonderful this thing is
right or how much it needs to be
protected no the other people
can't i can complacency
that's another possible way of doing
obstinacy
right desire excitement she talks about
although
these are a little bit different she
says
it helps to populate the world with
desirable objects with exciting
meanings but in the passions she says
which we call maniacal
to distinguish them from gen generous
passions
freedom does not find its genuine form
freedom does not find its genuine form
in this kind of
maniacal as opposed to generous passion
why
because the attempt is to get possession
and thereby to attain being
and so you know she gives some examples
here he causes rare treasures to appear
in the world but he also depopulates it
nothing exists outside of his stubborn
product nothing can induce him to modify
his choices there's the
obstinacy right having involved his
whole life with an external object which
can
continually escape him he tragically
feels his
dependence even if it does not
definitely disappear
the object never gives itself they're
never
entirely fulfilled they're constantly
seeking they're constantly
praising they're constantly protecting
and so they they never attain the true
satisfaction
and seeking this possession leads to
isolation from others
why well because they don't share that
she says that's why although the
passionate person inspires a certain
admiration
they also inspire a kind of horror you
can admire the pride of a subjectivity
which chooses its end without bending
itself to any foreign law
and the precious brilliance of the
object revealed by the force of this
but we have to consider the solitude
into which this subjectivity
encloses itself as injurious
withdrawing into an unusual region of
the world
seeking not to communicate with other
humans this freedom
is realized only as a separation any
conversation any relationship with a
passionate person
is impossible so she says in the eyes of
those who desire a communion of
freedom he therefore appears as a
stranger an obstacle
he's on the way to tyranny she says and
this is where we get to
this imposition of the passion
upon others they in one respect they
withdraw from others
into the the seeking the protecting of
their passionate object
in the other case they might impose this
passionate object or the pursuit of it
on others not saying that everybody
should pursue this
object but everyone should cooperate in
their pursuit
of this object and she talks about a
partial nihilism here
she says only the object of his passion
appears real and full to him
all the rest are insignificant why not
betray
kill grow violent it's never nothing one
destroys
so the entire universe she says can be
perceived as an
ensemble a totality of means and
obstacles to that
object of passion that the person is
investing
with all of this value so
she goes on and she says not intending
his freedom for other people
the passionate person does not recognize
them
as freedoms he will not hesitate to
treat them
as things as mere objects
to get this other object he doesn't he
doesn't care about what they're
passionate about
except insofar as it can coincide with
his own
quest for the passionate thing and this
makes them you know
kind of dangerous in in in certainly
going to
treat other people as less than than
people
and she goes on and says this can take
the form of fanaticism
when the passionate thing is a maybe a
state of the world
or of society she says the values
invented
by certain men in a passion of hatred
fear
or faith are thought and willed by
others as given realities but there's no
serious fanaticism
which does not have a passional base all
adhesion to the serious world is brought
about by repressed tendencies and
complexes
so maniacal passion represents a
damnation
for the one who chooses it and for
others it is one of the forms of
separation
which disunites freedoms which puts us
at odds
with each other as well it leads to
struggle and oppression
now she does also talk about
a possible conversion from this this is
where it gets very
interesting there could be a way of
getting
out of this even with the the
passionate attachment to something so
she gives the example
of mademoiselle de lepinos
who is grieving uh to the and she passes
from that to the assumption
of the grief the lover describes her
tears and her tortures
she asserts she loves this unhappiness
it is a source of delight for her
she likes the other to appear as another
through their separation
granting freedom to the other person
granting
individuality personhood to to the other
and it doesn't even alway
always have to be personhood to the
other it could be
she's got a great example here of loving
a land
if a person prefers the land they have
discovered to the possession of the land
insofar as they appear to that person as
possibilities open to other people
they're able to say
something like i want this to be this is
so
valuable it's so valuable that i don't
have to possess
it it doesn't have to just be mine and
that's a generosity that's a certain
kind of
love which renounces possession
very different than the amorous passion
that she was talking about
earlier this is a possibility of
detaching oneself from what we want one
has
invested oneself in and she says that
you cannot love a pure thing in its
independence and its separation for the
thing does not have positive
independence
it means not just loving the thing but
loving others
loving other human beings so she she
goes on and she says
passion is converted to genuine freedom
if one destines one's
existence to other existences through
the being
whether thing or man at which he aims
without hoping to entrap it in the
destiny of the in itself without
reducing it
merely to an object to be dominated
so the passionate person is treating
their
passion they're passionately loved
object desired object
uh as something to to control to to
dominate
one can go beyond that and thereby
relinquish it into a world
of others and their freedom
you